la femme
je la paye
prouver que le roi qu'est la country ne
sont pas réservées au groupe américain
c'est le pari de ce jeune trio yvelinois
1 sont accrocheurs et moderne où
résonnent des riffs dans la plus pure
tradition de 12 des influences variées
mais un style très personnel
j'écoute beaucoup de musique différente
j'ai commencé surtout par le rock et
leur rock avec des groupes comme ac/dc
deep purple led zeppelin et après je
suis allé chercher leur inspiration 1
pour comprendre le coup je suis parti
vers blues puis après l'ancien blues le
delta blues qui est plus plus anciens
quand on voit beaucoup de coups blues
mais qui chante en français et qui font
un espace de on va dire de deux copies
des américains et nous ce qu'on essaie
de faire c'est de prendre ses influences
là mais de faire quand même notre propre
son
[Musique]
un son reconnaissable grâce à la voix
grave et rocailleuse de fabien fondateur
du projet formé à la tech music school
de londres et au cfpm de paris il crée
de john walker en 2013 et sort un
premier album plutôt acoustique
c'est à partir de 2017 et le pay al
masri que le groupe prend une tournure
plus électrique
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
ayant commencé la guitare à 7 ans fabien
est aujourd'hui professeur et consacre
tout son temps à cet instrument sa
passion ils pensent ses compositions
pour emmener l'auditeur au coeur des
régions sudiste
c'est l'amérique du sud on va dire le
delta du mississippi tous à épier
nashville aussi avec la contribution
mans donc à la guitare slide et
commerces équipés de rials la guitare
qui joue beaucoup aussi le fait de jouer
sur 1,8 à résonateur des premières
guitares amplifiées en fait il n'y avait
pas d'ampli électrique à l'époque et du
coup ils ont fait un système de caunes
en métal pour faire résonner le sont
beaucoup plus forts en fait
le groupe se retrouvent chaque semaine
pour répéter actuellement il enregistre
son deuxième album à la batterie de
guyancourt on garde toujours cette
essence de la mousserie rajoutant des
morceaux dans cette veine là qu est ce
que plus d'une dizaine de nouvelles
compos depuis l'année dernière
facile donc c'est le bon moment pour un
pour les orages sortie prévue en 2019
pour découvrir sur scène le delta blues
corrosif de jay walker
rendez vous à la fête de la musique
[Musique]